thank you thank you thank you thanks
thank you thank you thank you thank you
for saying that oh
thank you hey guys my name is Ken Daniel
and I'm going to read there's twit yep
[Music]
here we go hang down your groove
I know what is meaning yeah it means
I'm hot
thank you I just want to say King Daniel
has absolutely no right who gave him the
right to look so fine
I want King Daniel apps so oh
I mean you can have it
it's at home the chest the shoulders the
muscles the lips came down your
stomaching me crazy oh did I make you
crazy please please let me with your
lips King Daniel I deserved it oh
um
let's see
showing his beastly muscles with his
cute Disney face expressions jewelry
never be a mystery cute face
[Music]
I'm not cute
King Daniel come down W the veins you
little boy Brad buddy
yeah oh
the saxophone is
saying Daniel is too hot too hot
oh
thank you
thank you ever since I had that sex
dream about King Daniel I haven't been
the same
day
I'm a for King Daniel no no no no
no
you don't have to say that you don't
have to say the word no no King Daniel
can't step on me his new song is poor
asphalt
why
oh there wow appreciate it
if America got Steve Rogers as as
America's ass than Korean Korea got King
Daniel's ass
that is South Korea's national ass all
right so if my butt is National National
ball wow thank you for saying that
Paranoia by King Daniel actually unlocks
The Forbidden level of horror within me
oh really
whoa
anyway thanks yeah that's it I'm
creating a cult where we worship King
Daniel's lights who wants to join me
I'm gonna wash it myself yay my only
personality
nowadays is sharing Daniel music video
and stages it's true I'm King Daniels
foreign
did I have a jawline
no sometimes his face looks so sharp
sometime it looks more round one magic
oh Jacob again
thank you can someone explain to me why
all of Korea wants to eat King Daniel's
ass what what no no it's gonna be hurt
don't bite Daniel can't spit on my face
foreign
I will eat your ass be gently okay
that was the last question uh I feel
dizzy I can take this
heart to me oh yeah thank you guys for
for yeah
about my ass and
my muscles I keep working hard okay
foreign
[Music]